thank you and thank everybody thank you
all for sticking around despite the very
long gap when you could have easily
escaped so this is a totally different
talk then I said I was going to talk on
so if you're interested in integer
partitions I'm happy to talk to you
about that but this is what I'm going to
talk about today so this is joint work
with my current students are a cannon
who's here and former student Sarah
miracle who's at the University of st.
Thomas and it only now occurs to me it's
a little bit like George Foreman they
make all of his children George okay so
this is what I'm going to be looking at
a class of imagine you have an N by n
square and you're dividing it into n
rectangles lattice rectangles of area n
ok so all of the vertices of the
rectangles lie on lattice points I'm
pretending that it actually has some
applications and ok and this is the
Markov chain I'm going to look at you
choose an edge and if that's an edge
that could be flipped rotated 90 degrees
then then you do that right so guess
this has a pointer somewhere but I'm
nothing ok then you could make this move
I'm hoping that those of you who have
been here for the whole workshop this
looks familiar so the questions that
make sense to ask is does this even
connect the state space ok so for
triangulations which we looked at
previously it's easier to show here it's
really not obvious and in fact the first
thing you'll realize is that n has to be
a power of 2 or this makes no sense so
if you try if you look at this
configuration there's no move you could
possibly do so we're going to always
assume that n is 2 to the K and then you
know the question that will really be
looking at is is this chain rapidly
mixing does it mix in polynomial time ok
and i just want to point out that this
exact edge flip chain comes up in a lot
of different settings so
the most obvious is Domino tilings so
this is the dual to perfect matchings on
the Cartesian lattice and if you look at
it in terms of actual thick dominoes
you're just taking the middle edge and
rotating and it's exactly the same edge
flip Jane this was the one that we saw a
couple of talks on earlier in the week
which is lattice triangulations again
you remove the edge and you try to put
it back in the other orientation the
other two things I'm comparing it to are
a little bit different but I want to
just sort of point out the similarity
this is lozenge tilings so here you're
taking you're not moving a single edge
you're actually taking a y-shape and
rotating it to an upside down why and
I'm saying it's similar because really
the similarity here at least is that
you're taking faces and you're
alternating edges your moves are
switching the edges around some face as
it is for there's been work it's called
fortresses because of the dual problem
but this is just a perfect matching on
the square octagon lettuce and if i
wanted to generate a random one i can
choose a face and if the edges around
the face alternating are part of the
matching i could rotate it to the other
one in this connects estate space
alright so the top two are known to be
polynomial amidst mixing the bottom two
we don't know and you know as we saw
there's a lot of work on this question
in the unweighted case this one is
almost definitely slowly mixing and
there's been some work on weighted
models that show when the weights are
high this is slow and when they're fast
and when it's low it's fast and in
between we don't know and this is
unfortunately in between okay so let's
talk a little bit let me just remind you
what we had for triangulations okay so
in general you could ask this question
where the vertices are not necessarily
on lattice points and look for a random
triangulation and this is a problem that
a lot of people in graphics are
interested in this is open it's been
solved if the vertices are all
in convex positions say the vertices of
a convex and gone where you know all the
combinatorics are solved also so you
could generate these things in other
ways as well but this edge flipping
chain is fast in that case we saw
already that triangulations of regions
on ZD this is still open but this is
very nice work by Caputo and
collaborators who are all here that
looks at the weighted setting ok so what
they show is this ok so they wait the
configuration by lambda to the total
edge length and they consider this
Markov chain and they show that when
lambda is greater than one you have
exponential time convergence when lambda
is less than one it seems fast and they
show it rigorously up to some lower
value lambda 0 and there's a lot of
evidence certainly including the work
that Alex talked about that suggests
that it's going to be faster all the way
up to 1 but this is the current state so
this motivated our question which is you
know really when I heard about that work
when they were doing it I thought you
know you could probably see the same
effect if you consider rectangles
instead which is why we started thinking
about this so it's a lot less rich of a
problem you're not going to get these
shears in many different directions like
you do with triangulations but in terms
of demonstrating this type of phase
transition this seemed like a simpler
model to look at so sorry let me go back
so again i'm going to take lambda to the
int us to the total edge length of my
rectangle ation so long thin ones have
longer length and square root end by
root and rectangles have smaller
perimeter or you know smaller exponent
ok and here are two examples so this is
when lambda is less than 1 you're
favoring squares right when lambda is
greater than one you're favoring long
thin ones and the long thin ones are
going to align vertically or they're
going to align horizontally and that
suggests that you're going to have a
phase transition ok so this was my
intuition it turns
to be completely wrong so we'll see why
later but hopefully this is at least
suggesting that there's it's not
completely wrong all right ok so I'm
interested in how fast okay so I want to
know does the edge flip chain even
connect the state space is I have to
answer first okay before I even look at
things like mixing and I just want to
point out but I mean these pictures
might not make it obvious but it's not
obvious that there's always a single
move you can do okay so for there to be
a single move for there to be a move you
have to have two identical rectangles
next to each other completely not
obvious to us that that's always the
case okay so our first result is that
the edge flip chain does connect the
state space okay so the whole mixing
question makes sense will converge to
the uniform distribution if you do that
ok so again it's not obvious that
there's a move it's a double induction
that I credit Sarah for that ended up
every time we thought we had it there
was a counter example it's really messy
and so we do induction on something we
call h regions so H is a power of 2 and
all of the rectangles within an H region
have height at most h and all of the
vertical walls are a multiple of H so
that defines the sub regions and if you
have some tall regions or some you know
toll things we're going to try to retile
it with rectangles that have half the
height and convert it into an H over 2
region okay so it's sort of an involved
induction and this is not i'm not going
to go through this anymore but there is
a proof that this connects the state
space
okay so I want to look at this question
and it turns out that it's um we were
really stuck on this for a while and
you'll see by the end of the talk why
this is actually maybe not the right
question to ask so we're going to switch
instead to a restricted subset of the
tilings which are called dyadic tilings
or a subset of the dissections which are
called iotic tilings so I'm going to
just take a few minutes and tell you
about first define them because you need
to know what they are but also they have
this just beautiful combinatorial
structure and I'm just going to give you
some background on dyadic tilings
because they're really lovely ok then
we'll consider the general case all
right so a dyadic rectangle is a
rectangle whose height and whose height
and width are both dyadic intervals hey
okay yes everything is a power of two
exactly right so they I have 2 to the K
by 2 to the K square and I'm filling it
with 2 to the K is n so n rectangles of
area n so it won't connect the
state-space event is not a power herb
too ok so I'm restricting to a subset of
the rectangular Sheen's where each
rectangle both dimensions are dyadic so
dyadic intervals are this is formally
what it is but it's something where
you're going from you know a over 2 to
the B to a plus 1 over 2 to the day and
if you think about the kind of ruler
function if you connect the tops of this
line and this line you don't cross
anything in between but here you do and
so this is not dyadic you can't express
it in that reduced form as a over 2 to
the B and a plus 1 over 2 to the be so
just to be clear a dyadic tiling all of
these rectangles are dyadic here we have
the dark ones are not dyadic rectangles
because they have intervals which are
not dyadic so obviously this is a very
small subset of the
rectangular dissections okay but it
turns out that the same edge flip chain
does connect the set of dyadic tilings
so we're going to look at that first and
here the proof is very easy unlike the
general case and I should say that it's
it's obvious and probably doesn't need
an attribution but this is something
that i did with sponte onsen and Jill
Spencer at while ago okay so here's the
most important theorem in dyadic
rectangles that lets you do everything
else or dyadic tilings is that every
dyadic tiling has a fault line that's
either horizontal and bisects the
rectangle and doesn't cross any
rectangles or a horizontal one it's a as
soon as you play with it you'll see it
might have both okay and once you
realize that if a k is the number of
tilings with two okay so I'm just
scaling down so it has two to the K
rectangles of area 2 to the minus K so
this is now a unit square I just changed
the scaling in a theorem of coffman and
company and liguria spence and company
is that if you start there's a very
simple recurrence so a 0 is 1 a 1 if
you're having if you're dividing it with
one dividing line you could either do it
horizontally or vertically so there's
two and the recursion is that for a k if
you divide it this way you can take the
left side and rescale it right so you
dilate it to a square again and you have
a dyadic tiling of one lower order so
all of your rectangles double in size
but you get another one back of the
smaller order so you have a k minus 1
squared for vertical you have a k minus
1 squared if you divided horizontally
and we've over counted by the ones that
have both so you subtract off AK minus 2
to the fourth where you would have to
dilate you would have to stretch in both
directions
okay so we have this very simple
recurrence it should look familiar and
you know we know that it's the golden
mean to the end so we know everything
about the number of dyadic tilings
including the asymptotic behavior and so
if you wanted to sample these you could
choose vertical or horizontal right and
then on each side if you choose vertical
you could choose horizontal or vertical
with the right probabilities and you
just do this recursively recursively and
you're producing what we call a vh tree
okay and the only restriction on these
it's not all possibilities we're going
to say that if something divides both
ways we're going to allow a V with two
H's children and we're never going to
allow an H with two visas children so
this resolves the ambiguity and then
conditioned on this there's a bijection
between these labeled binary trees and
the tilings so you could figure out
exactly the probability to put V or H in
a given place and you could just
generate these and you could also do it
for the infinite tilings you could do
windows of the infinite tilings okay but
we looked then at this edge flip pain
sorry in the context of dyadic tilings
and it's still open we don't know how to
do it but we did find a different Markov
chain that's rapidly mixing and I'm just
going to show you what it is it's you
choose this blue window is a dyadic
rectangle of larger size and everything
in it we can rotate it 90 degrees and
rescale as necessary to reach to put
that tiling back in so if you look at
what's here these two become these two
long thin ones and these two become
these two so all I did is I took this
and I rotated it to the left and i got a
new tiling so this is a chain that i
could implement in polynomial time and
it turns out that it's really simple to
show that this chain is rapidly mixing
day but it doesn't tell us anything
about the edge flip train unfortunately
okay so the same thing that I showed you
before we're going to consider these
weighted versions where the weight of a
tiling is going to be lambda to the
total edge length and here are some
samples so again you see something that
is suggestive we're here your guess is
correct you're going to have a lot of
squares when lambda is less than 1 and
things should mix quickly you're going
to have a lot of long thin rectangles
when lambda is greater than 1 and things
should mix slowly because you won't go
from predominantly vertical
configuration to a predominantly
horizontal one and at one who knows and
this is what we show so the work with
Sarah cannon and Sarah miracle we show
that we have polynomial mixing all the
way up to the critical point and an
exponential mixing all the way beyond
the critical point so this is what was
suggested from the trying the triangular
triangulation picture but here we're
able to show it all the way to the
critical point okay
so what about general rectangular
dissections all right so this is in the
case that all of your your rectangles
were restricted to hubby dyadic
intervals here the picture is much more
complicated I mean even showing
connectivity was much more complicated
any guesses
here's the picture so we have
exponential mixing below one we have
exponential mixing above one for a
totally different reason and we don't
know about one but I actually suspect
that it's fast at one okay so hopefully
by the end of the talk I'll explain why
I mean at a high level above one you're
going to be slow starting anywhere and
below one you're probably fast if you
started a good place so they're going to
be some places that are slow so when I
say it's slow mixing it's some this
qualitative differences in what I mean
by that okay so my goal is to prove
these theorems to you so in the dyadic
case i want to show that you have this
phase transition and in the other case i
want to show that it's exponential above
and below trivial I mean so you could
there's at least
yeah I mean there's an exponential
number of each the exponential in the
case of dyadic tilings is the golden
mean because you solved that recurrence
and it's a larger I mean you have a much
larger number in the case of general we
don't have good bounds but we have crude
bounds that show it's much larger so we
have I think it's um log in to the end
as a lower bound so it's different yeah
Tom in fact one might say that we're
interested in sampling so that we could
estimate that it's I mean we're saying
it in n by n regions so unless you
generalize that definition it's not self
reducible but presumably it is what if
you pull that bhp and flipped all these
pages native old movies and that's the
one thing that's stopping you would
violate the condition that I had this
asymmetry where I said you could have a
V with two aged children but not an H
with two V children
so I mean you would get a different I
mean you would have to have a different
you would have to compensate for that
yeah well i'm going to show you that i
see at the high yeah i mean very
definitely I mean my guess honestly a
different way of saying what you're
saying is what if we add moves that
allow you to take sub regions and rotate
by 90 degrees I suspect this is fast
what if you take sub regions and rotate
by a hundred eighty degrees this will
still be slow but I suspect this one is
fast and we've done simulations and I'll
show you at the end so there's very
closely related chains that will draw
out the differences between these two
exponential regions but yeah I agree
that that should break this imagery okay
so this is in the green the one green
bar that I have which is lambda less
than one where I'm favoring squares in
the dyadic restricted case okay so in
this case we show that we have N squared
log in mixing and our proof technique is
exactly what they did with the
triangulations is exactly the same
strategy we're going to we have this
exponential metric essentially defined
oh it is i just changed it i had just
letters and then I congratulations
Katniss greenberg tesco and Randall I
apologize thank you so right so if we
have two configurations that differ by
an edge move the distance between them
is lambda to the difference in their
lengths and we show that there's a
coupling that gets closer together in
expectation at each step and the rest is
standard okay so the trick here is
defining this metric so that you could
show that there's contraction in
expectation and then we use the original
bubbly Dyer multiplicative version of
the path coupling lemma gives this to
you so this is pretty standard for both
of them I'm going to be able to show
that when lambda is greater than 1 this
is the regime where you're favoring long
thin rectangles it's the same proof in
both cases we're going to show that the
chain is slow okay so
right so we're going to show that it's
exponential in N squared the mixing at
least okay so we're going to show that
there's a bottleneck in the state space
so that it's hard to cross from one side
to the other because you have this
exponential constriction so what are my
the left set is going to be that there's
at least one long thin rectangle the
right set is going to be that there is
oh I'm saying the middle first the right
set is going to be that you have a wide
rectangle going all the way across and
the middle set is you have none of those
okay and this is a partition and
moreover to get from here to here you
have to pass through this middle set
okay so you have to kind of reason that
through but it's pretty straightforward
okay and then we do very crude estimates
I mean these are really simple so if you
have at least one
oh right this set includes the all
vertical the configuration where
everything is vertical this is the
weight of that one configuration so the
weight of the entire set is at least
that on the right side we have the
configuration that is all horizontal
which has this weight so the weight of
the right side is at least this the
middle side you have to be a little bit
careful but the largest size of any
rectangle the largest perimeter is if
it's half the height because it can't be
the entire height all right so this is
the largest size of any rectangle this
is the number of configurations you
could have ok so namely you take your
lower left corner that has not yet been
mapped to a rectangle and it's part of
erecta it's the lower left corner of one
of log and different rectangles ok that
I mean that we have log and different
rectangles that could possibly be part
of a tiling you take that out and then
you choose the lexicographically lowest
point remaining and you do the same
thing so this is an upper bound on the
number of possible rectangular tilings
so it's an upper bound and not a lower
bound which is what I said before but
this is enough to show you that you have
an exponential difference and you have a
bad cut ok so this was pretty
straightforward this was the one that
was surprising to us so it's probably
still a little bit of a mystery mystery
why when lambda is less than 1 so this
is the case where we're favoring squares
why should this be slow alright so this
is what I'm going to try to show and so
what happens and we didn't realize this
until we did simulations is that if you
have a configuration that has two long
thin rectangles remember those are the
ones we want to get rid of right away
right the favorable configurations don't
have any of these when lambdas less than
one but if they're separated they have
to be next to each other to annihilate
them right so if they're next to each
other we can do an edge move
but if they're far apart we can't get
rid of one of them until we introduce
more rectangles in order to move them
closer or to do something where we could
get rid of it right okay so this is the
problem so if you have two separated
bars it turns out that like everything
we tried in order to show a bad cut in
the state space still didn't work it was
sort of challenging to figure out how to
characterize this we could show that you
know the middle set had to have lower
weight but we weren't able to show an
exponential exponentially small cut
until we realize that if things are
separated at some precise distances then
you also have to have a lot of things at
the next smaller scale and so forth ok
so the binary representation of the
distance is significant in showing a
lower bound on what the weight has to be
and so here was the what we ended up
showing ok so we define the separation
as if you have at least two verticals
the long belong you know the tallest
possible bars there has to be an even
number and I'm going to pair them up in
order and the separation is the distance
between this pair plus the distance
between this pair ok you know and
intuitively the separation is what met
it doesn't really matter how far these
are apart because these two have to get
closer together to annihilate and
they're sort of going to interact with
each other you know there's definitely a
parity thing going on here so our middle
set here is going to be configurations
that have at least four vertical bars
and separation exactly equal to n over 2
plus 2 this really precise crazy little
set our left set is going to be things
that have separation at least n over 2
plus 2 and
yeah so it's at least this and it should
be strictly greater unless there are two
bars okay so and this set is when the
separation is less okay so everything
that does not have these long thin bars
which is the majority of the state space
is all in this giant set okay so in this
case there's a definite asymmetry but if
you think about it if you have something
which has large separation either it has
a lot of bars or it just has two bars
that are well separated all you can do
with edge flip moves if you're going to
change the signature in terms of the
long thin bars is you could move them
two at a time closer together okay so
you could introduce another so you're
moving up or down by some very small
amount and that means that if this is
separation which is larger and you're
moving to separation which is smaller
you have to go through the set and if
you have two bars that are well
separated you have to get to this amount
with poor vertical bars okay so it
sounds like overly technical but you
really need this kind of structure all
right this and I mean we could have put
any distance here would have partitioned
the state space this distance was chosen
precisely so that if we write out the
binary representation of the distance
we're going to have a lot of ones which
means that you you have these two things
that are well separated but you can't
fill in the in-between thing with
squares okay you have to have at least
two and over to height rectangles above
each other you have to have at least two
of those and then what's remaining you
still can't fill in with squares so you
have to have some n over 4 sized
rectangles and you just do this by
arguing over the dimensions of the space
between and with that you're able to get
enough structure that you can show that
this set is exponentially smaller than
either of the other two so I went very
fast yep those initial conditions take
exponential time to escape but do you
think that what I said before is from a
warm start I think it's fast I think
that lambda less than 1 will be fast
from a warm start and greater than one
will of course be slow yeah so I mean
they are qualitatively different or it
would be really ridiculous to look at
this picture and say I think it's fast
here but I do ok so i think that at
lambda equal to one probably both of
these are fast which is what they
believe in the triangulation case too i
think ok so open questions is what
happens at lambda equal to one either
for the dyadic case or the non-diet a
case so remember that when lambda is
equal to one there is this other markov
chain which is fast which says choose
larger regions and rotate those ok which
by the way is very similar to the chain
that Robbie was suggesting in the you
know which is like choose pieces and try
to you know this idea of rotation seems
to be breaking the cut the phase
transition that says you're going to be
largely vertical or largely horizontal I
mean I think that should work in the
case of dyadic tilings if you choose
these rectangles to be any dyadic
sub-region we do know it's fast here but
that doesn't tell us anything for the
for the single edge flip the original
chain ok I also you know I talked about
this earlier so what if we allow 90
degree or 180 degree rotations with the
appropriate stretching or shrinking to
fit things in when it's still in the
class ok so here are some simulations
so we started with we Sarah started with
these are N equals 64 lambda is point
eight okay so at the she started with
the old vertical configuration which
doesn't have these two well separated
bars but it's in the left set that small
set that we would have to cross over to
reach equilibrium so you know after 20
million moves you still have a fair
number of verticals left and then it
starts smoothing out and then after 60
million it already looks like it's at
equilibrium you really get rid of these
these long thin obstacles in either
direction and you have things that look
mostly like squares so I do think that
if you add 180 degree rotations I mean
if you think about it we're doing 180
degree rotations on any sub rectangle so
if you have two long thin rectangles
that are separated and you grab
everything right next to one of them in
one move you could get those next to
each other okay and that's the benefit
so when lambda is less than 1 this is
going to bring rectangles close together
and then you could annihilate them
quickly in the case where lambda is
greater than 1 it's not going to help at
all because it's going to map long thin
things too long thin things and it's not
going to help you because you have a lot
of them and they're not going to
disappear so quickly right so that was
this question I you know this idea of
choosing sub rectangles and trying to do
a rotation there I thought about it a
little bit and didn't really see what to
do with it but for people who are
looking at triangulations it might be
possible to choose some convex region
and rotate the triangulation within that
and break symmetry so there might be
sort of an analog of this in the
triangulation case you're going to have
long thin regions so that's not going to
break those so easily but it might be
adding those moves you'll get out of
these sort of stuck situations where
things are well sheared you
and you thought about reflections of sub
rectangles reflections aren't going to
help because it's all I mean unless I do
reflections over the diagonal because
the whole move safely now files at the
top from espares at the bottom then you
could fit those up at the top you but
yeah okay I think I think it would have
the same effect as the 180-degree
rotation yeah i agree with that yeah I
thought you meant in the larger yeah
absolutely i think it does i mean i
think the only obstacle i think it's an
artifact for the general rectangular
shins is that you get stuck with these
long sep these long thin separated
things that just can't breach each other
so anything you do to break that should
help okay and there's actually a lot of
structure here so there's there's a lot
of nice questions about Alex refer to
them in the talk when he was talking
about triangulations you know can you
say anything about decay of correlations
in both of these regimes can you say
anything about average edge length and I
imagine here these problems are far more
tractable certainly in the dyadic
setting where we really do get this nice
phase transition I mean all of these
problems probably a lot of this is known
already in fact but I haven't looked
into it so I think that you know to get
intuition for the triangulation model
which I again is a much richer model I
think this potentially is helpful and
thank you
so is there a high function tomorrow
like this this module sorry in the day
attitude it depends what you mean it
doesn't have the kind of structure but
the each square is associated with the
log of the height of the rectangle it
falls in right so so you implicitly have
a height function that when you talk
about like the distance between two
you're looking at cell by cell at that
difference so you know there's something
sort of implicit here but I I don't
think there's anything that we can
exploit in ways that we can for other
models and it's sort of a distance
metric we're using to show that it's
decreasing is the difference in height
so have you considered sort of changing
the square into a rectangle we saw this
this way out I mean I think you would
have exactly the same oh actually it
might change what happens a greater than
one but because you have an asymmetry
but even there I doubt it i think you're
going to get stuck in one or the other
but i don't know but less than one it's
not going to make a difference because
you're still going to have these long
thin things that are well separated that
you're not going to get rid of quickly
in the general case right and it did I
had a case I'm not sure even make sense
so Russia so along the same lines what
is it weird of course well then things
are not connected right so I mean you
just you have a horizontal all the way
across and then the next one offset so
the edge flip chain I mean you could ask
does is the edge flip chain in the
region that's connected for the set of
configurations that are connected but I
don't know yeah I imagine it's similar